[Music]
it's a great pleasure to be here with
all of you at Stanford I was here three
years ago and a lot has happened over
the last three years and I view this as
an opportunity for us to exchange views
with the panelists we've already met
with members of the faculty and with all
of with all of you so about 15 minutes
let me just dive straight in about the
change that has occurred over the last
three years if you told me three years
ago when I was here that today
impact would be a mainstream subject of
conversation I would have been very
impressed and what we have discovered
over the last three years I think partly
for reasons of political populism which
has being based on anti-immigration
feelings which has brought with it
frustrations about the inequalities that
our society creates the disparities in
the amounts held by those who were lucky
enough to be able to benefit from the
deployment of capital and those who have
continued to receive remuneration for
their work and all of those pressures
are leading to phenomena that we cannot
ignore when you look at the migration
trends today not just in countries like
the United States but across the whole
of Europe now when you look at the
brexit vote when you look at the
religion in France when you look at the
Trump phenomenon here in the United
States these are all examples of the
consequences of our existing system
and my view is that the majority of us
today feel that the world cannot go on
in the way that it is doing something
has got to change and what I'd like to
discuss with you today is what is it
that has to change because capitalism
has served us very well for 250 years
but we're at a stage where the
consequences of the capitalist system
are so great the governments can't cope
with them so we're finding governments
across the world basically looking at
social issues and environmental issues
without having the tools or the
resources to be able to bring credible
responses to them and philanthropists so
who deploy just 5% of what governments
deploy on health and education alone
five to six hundred billion dollars a
year can't bring the answer either and
so the conclusion has to be that the
private sector has to begin to get
involved in finding solutions to the
social and environmental issues at scale
and I started off from this track in
2000 18 years ago when the government
asked me in the UK to look at the issue
of poverty and for the last 18 years I
have been trying to work out how is it
that our system can go through a
transformation that leads to much better
outcomes than we are witnessing today
and through the work of social finance
the development of the first social
impact bombed in 2010 where for the
first time we developed the security
whose financial return depended on the
impact delivered in this particular case
the Peterborough bombed how many young
prisoners
would go back to Peterborough jail after
their release across the world as most
of you know 60% go back within 18 months
of release and so we invented the first
social impact bomb that was launched in
three months just three months because
an election was spending and the
Minister wanted it to be signed in time
and what was the result
five million pounds funded three or four
not-for-profits that had been dealing
with prisoners for years going cap in
hand to raise donations after five years
we reduced the number going back to jail
by 10% and investors made 3% a year on
their money and got their money back and
through that through the creation of big
society capital the first social
investment bank in the UK which I was
privileged to co-found with Nick
O'Donoghue funded by bank account money
that had been separated from its owners
for fifteen years or more and just
stayed on the balance sheets of the
banks that money was released and with a
billion dollars worth of money we
created the social investment bank and
began to bring investment to
not-for-profits and then the g8
experience were matt was a very loyal
partner and active partner where we
began to create boards in each of the
leading industrialized their countries
of the world and get feedback on what
was going on with social issues in these
countries and it was then that the
lightbulb the second light bulb came on
after the social impact bond light bulb
and that light bulb boils we know what
values are changing young people want
more meaning than just making money they
want to be able to impact favorably the
lives of
the people young people connect with
others in far away countries they
identified with them and perhaps they
understand that they're going to inherit
a very problematic planet if nothing is
done now the second thing is older
people older people who are making
pension contributions with an eye to
receiving their pension a beginning to
wonder what type of a world they're
gonna retire in what's the use of having
a pension if you're living in the
strife-torn neighborhood or country and
those pressures brought us to the
conclusion that the shift which is going
to happen within our system is going to
be revolutionary it may result from an
evolution in thinking of several decades
but it is revolutionary in the means
that it is going to bring to tackling
social and environmental issues and that
is to shift our mindset from making
decisions in business and in investment
on the basis of just risk and return to
making them on the basis of risk return
and measurable impact and when you begin
to adopt that mindset you begin to
realize that bringing impact in changes
both the risk element and the return
element and that you may be able if you
are a profit with purpose business as
we're calling them today to grow faster
and to be more profitable and to help
many more people then a company that
just worried about risk and return and
so
when I look through the lens of the
global steering group today which is
working in 21 countries soon to be 30
countries across the globe I see young
people like many of you everywhere
saying if I want to create a business
let that business help people's lives
let it help the planet and I'm not
trading off the upside potential I can
actually think I can build a global
company that helps billions of people
maybe the definition of a new impact
unicorn will be a company that's worth a
billion dollars but also touches the
lives of a billion people and I find
young people innovating I begin to see
platforms to help those who less well
off budget to refinance their loans at a
lower price
I see technology coming in to help the
visually impaired a company in Israel
called Oakham founded by the
entrepreneurs who sold out to Intel for
15 billion dollars the aunt of one of
the entrepreneurs was partially blind
she asked her nephew to help her several
years later a couple of decades later he
felt his technology had reached the
stage where he could help his aunt so he
created a pair of spectacles with an
attachment that whispers into your ear
the page of the book you're reading the
name of the street sign the banknote in
your hand the goods on the supermarket
shelf company has raised a hundred
million dollars so far the last round
was a six hundred million dollar
valuation evaluation a non impact
business would have been very proud to
have
but even here to illustrate what I mean
about bringing in the impact lens if you
put an impact lens on and you ask
yourself the question how can I help the
maximum number of lives
it takes you beyond blind people maybe
it takes you to saying what if I gave a
pair of these spectacles to every
illiterate person in the world would
that enable them to get a higher paying
job improve the lives of their families
and so by bringing technology for good
by bringing entrepreneurship for impact
by working through not-for-profits where
you can raise investment capital this
impact revolution is going to take place
led by the young people in this hall and
if I look ahead the mainstream
conversation has already altered capital
flows do you know the two trillion
dollars of capital are potentially
flowing to impact investment we're
already at the quarter of that we can
see another one-and-a-half trillion in
the pipeline 20 trillion have already
gone to ESG investing ESG investing
where very little is measured but where
environmental social and governance
investing but where there is an
intention to create positive impact and
for this revolution to take place those
of you who are at the business school
have to focus on how we measure impact
because if we can put impact measurement
I'm twenty-two trillion of ESG money
then we will be able to compare the
impact of different companies we would
look at their accounts we will have
their financial accounts and impact
weighted accounts where their bottom
line is different according to the net
impact that they have delivered
improving their sales line for the
positive impact their products deliver
reducing their employment line for the
positive employment impact that they
deliver and reducing their manufacturing
costs for the positive environmental and
social impact they deliver and so the
big challenge for us now rather like the
challenge after the 1929 crash when our
financial accounts were prepared on the
basis of the accounting policies that
each company chose each accounting firm
chose couldn't really be compared and
after the crash people looked at it and
said my god we're heading for disaster
if we continue with the system we have
to shift to generally accepted
accounting principles that make it
possible to compare the financial
performance of every company and I think
the 60 70 80 years that have followed
the since then show us the path the
generally accepted impact principles is
going to take we are going in the
direction and I think it will happen
within the within the coming decade
where companies will publish two sets of
accounts employees will look at the
impact weighted profit of a company
before deciding to work there
consumers will look at the same number
before deciding to purchase the products
of this company and the investors will
do the same and I'll just close
with my view of how this revolution is
going to take place the idea is a simple
one you optimize risk return impact you
bring impact to the center of our
consciousness the tools for doing it are
two broad categories of tools pay for
success tools like social impact bonds
development impact bonds
my colleague dr. Ahmad Coble is here in
the audience raising a billion dollar
outcomes fund to pay for pace for
success securities when education
attainment has improved in Africa and
the Middle East the first of many large
scale outcomes funds the second strand
is the measurement of impact within
traditional investment disciplines
private equity impact private equity
impact venture capital impact real
estate impact infrastructure the
movement part of it comes from consumers
employees and interestingly those making
contributions to pension funds how many
of you in the room have deductions made
from your salary those of you who work
into a pension plan right do you know
what's in your pension plan do you know
what the portfolio of your pension plan
is do you know what returns it's making
the movement may welcome from all of you
beginning to put pressure on the
trustees of the pension fund to define
ways of delivering the same financial
return while improving lives and the
planet now a great economist Adam Smith
talked about the invisible hand of
markets had he thought of impact
measurement
might have curved impact the invisible
heart of markets that guides their
invisible and thank you so I invite my
fellow panelists
[Applause]
a pleasure - and really an honor to
moderate a panel with three pioneers in
impact investing Heidi who was at new
island capital now runs a fun call we
think impact and it's currently teaching
a class at the GSB on investing for good
Matt Bernadette mentioned is has just
retired as the Managing Partner for MIDI
our network
he wrote together with some colleagues a
pioneering article in in impact
investing called beyond the returns
continuum which I others teach from and
is also a lecturer at the GSB teaching
assessing high-impact business models
and emerging markets and Sir Ronald
Cohen has been introduced several times
but I just want to mention that he's
called the father of British venture
capital and the father of social
investments and his one of his
organizations bridges funds management
is responsible for what I think is one
of the major initiatives in impact
investing called the impact management
project which is working on some of the
issues you mentioned about how to how to
measure impact the only thing missing
from Sir Ronald's curriculum vitae is
that he's not teaching it Stanford GSB
but but that may that may be remedied
you'll also notice that we've kind of
adjusted the weather to be a welcoming
some thank you okay so we they're really
two related issues that we can talk
about but I think the the energy right
now is for impact investing and if we
have time we'll come to social finance
and a question I'd like to maybe I'll
begin with with Heidi and Matt and then
turn to you you visited here three years
ago and this is a very fast changing
world what do you think has changed in
the impact investing universe over these
three years what do you think has
changed for good and where might you
have some worries
you want to begin
sure I think in the last three years
what's been really interesting is the
emergence of really large institutional
scale funds that have an impact lens so
some of those whether it's rethink
impact launching with over 100 million
bein double impact launching with
hundreds of millions or TPG rise fund
KKR others and I think what that's
enabling is really for folks to stop
thinking about impact investing as a
sleeve or a pilot that exists in
endowments our portfolio and really
something to use as a lens on all of
your portfolio and all the asset classes
no investment is exempt from scrutiny
using impact as a perspective so we're
seeing things like impact private credit
emerge as an asset class more and more
focus on impact VC impact private equity
ways to use real asset investing to
create impact I think it's this growing
acceptance that there is a spectrum when
it comes to impact and returned there's
a way to do this work that is quasi
philanthropic but I think more and more
as Sir Ronnie talked about there doesn't
have to be a trade off there can be
there can be a way to do this work where
there is convergence between financial
returns and high-impact transformational
impact and I think that growing
recognition is something we've really
seen come to the forefront in the last
few years so before turning to Matt you
talked about the positive side what's
what worries you what's the dark side of
this I think part of it is a question of
whether its impact authenticity on the
one hand folks who are coming into the
space without really having a background
and impact and not knowing necessarily
what the questions are to ask about
impact risks whether that's unintended
consequences mission drift negative
headlines but also who it is that's
doing the work you know Morgan Simon
wrote in her book what came out recently
called real impact that she and others
are recognizing a pattern with an impact
investing that mirrors what's happened
in conventional finance where there's a
concentration of capital and decision
making power in the hands of a few and
few who sort of look like this panel
in terms of ethnic background classic
education and how do we pay attention to
that to make sure that now that we're
creating a new industry from the ground
up to make sure that we have more
diverse voices included into how capital
allocation decisions get made into how
products get designed thank you yeah and
Paul if I may about ten years not just
three but ten years don't come back to
the three year observations but I think
we soon forget that ten years ago when
when I was about the time we became
really active at the middie our network
in this realm that's currently called an
impact investing what are one of our
objectives was to change the way people
think about social change
and driving social positive social
change and at a time business was really
not part of that equation it was seen as
the role of government or
not-for-profits and led by many in the
field including PR we said hold on
doesn't business have a role to play
aren't there ways to engage the private
sector in driving positive social change
so from the 10-year perspective is
actually quite amazing how far we've
come you know that comment that business
plays a role in driving positive social
change that was revolutionary ten years
ago and now I think it's kind of
generally accepted taking the three-year
view I think the lot more capital is
flowed in there's ever more enthusiasm
around impact investing Serrano look'n
talk about the more global movement that
we're seeing so a lot of momentum I have
a couple of concerns that I think bears
some attention one is the discussions we
sometimes the debates we sometimes get
in the relevant impact investing and the
most common one we get into and we had a
hint of this earlier was can you get
risk adjusted returns and and is that
still an impact investment and we get
into this yes you can no you can't yes
you can no you can with the real you
that I share is it depends and the point
isn't whether it's good or not to get
those risk adjusted returns the point is
ground yourself and what you're trying
to accomplish and be very clear-eyed
about what your returns are going to be
as you go forward and try to accomplish
that so I think we sometimes need to
maybe move beyond
the yes/no debates such as the one we
see with respect to returns the second
one and one of those I admire about
Ronnie is he's always out ahead working
on the on the next wave i I do think
there's a lot of impact washing out
there if there's a certain positive
cachet towards impact investing and
nobody's really asking you to measure
what you mean by positive impact why not
raise your hands and say I'm yes I'm an
impact investor if that means more money
absolutely I'm an impact investor I care
right I'm a caring person I'm an impact
investment who's really an impact
investor what defines an impact investor
and shouldn't impact play a role in that
and shouldn't there be an expectation
that you're an impact if you're an
impact investor that you think seriously
about impact and then you measure impact
so this whole notion of impact washing
is one that concerns me and I think the
the the antidote to that or the serious
work that needs to be done is digging in
more on how do we how do we define
impact how do we measure impact and I
think there's been some decent progress
recently on that so Ronald as as the
father of this field
how has your child done for a better
well I must say I'm very encouraged by
my child's progress I am worried about
several things but overall I think the
most important thing now is that we
begin to deliver measurable impact and
avoid this risk of discredit ation that
comes from people say everyone's talking
about impact but you look at what impact
these companies are creating they're not
doing anything they weren't doing before
impact washing in other words and that's
why at the GSG in partnership with the
InP and I hope with members of the
business school here we have to find the
framework for publishing impact weighted
accounts this is the next big challenge
I feel it's an achievable challenge I
think as I was saying in earlier
comments with the faculty I think where
environmentalism
impact is concerned with almost their
employment impact we're on the way to
that the big challenge is product impact
and for those of you who are going to
move into the Big Data area it may well
be that Big Data artificial intelligence
type tools enable us to get to a
feedback loop from consumers a bad value
for money affordability and and and and
so on so we have to think with the new
tools we have so I think impact washing
is the most worrying I think I have to
say that having lived through the birth
of venture capital
I see great parallels the challenge when
venture capital started was that there
weren't enough entrepreneurs around to
invest it and most investors most
investors said I'm gonna wait until this
get going before I get involved a small
number of investors including Tom judge
who was the leader of the AT&T pension
fund said this is gonna work I have
faith it's gonna work and I'm gonna get
an allocation to fund people like Heidi
here who are setting up professional
funds that are going to deliver
entrepreneurs that can change the world
basically
and I think allocations by investors
pool are something that we've got to try
to jump to now it's very difficult for
Heidi for bridges for leapfrog for
average gone to go to institutional
investment managers and say give us
money because today they say well it's
neither traditional venture capital
private equity nor do we have an
allocation to something called impact so
it's very difficult to raise money until
my second fear is that
we don't scale fast enough that we can
begin to prove the proposition that you
can deploy significant capital that
there are entrepreneurs like Elon Musk
who want to make a ton of money but at
the same time want to change the world
for the better
transform it for the better so there
seems to be a consensus that for all of
the all of the advances in the field
that the concern about impact washing
remains one and that the solution is
impact measurement or impact weighted
accounts you can you can think of impact
in two different categories one is the
investi enterprise the the business in
which you're investing is it producing
valuable social outputs and then you can
think about the the impact of the
investment itself let's begin with the
investees impact and there's a new
organization which which comes out of
TPG rise and called why analytics which
is trying I think to bring to the impact
investing field the same kinds of
measurements of outcomes as philanthropy
has brought to its grantees for many
years do you have a sense of how of
where that's where that's going and how
it's doing yeah now I'm involved in
advising why analytics I think they have
arrived that way of measuring impacts
and expressing it is a multiple of
capital invested that is workable it's
easier to do within a private equity
framework where most companies will be
single product companies rather than
multi product companies and I think it
will work I think the system will get
refined with inputs from many other
organizations but it is necessary and
what is fascinating about TPG is in the
space of three years they will have
raised five billion dollars
impact private equity five billion
dollars if you told me that when I was
there three years ago I would have
thought you were dreaming
five billion dollars and so I think Paul
we all have to do as we did with venture
capital we all have to do the effort to
make the effort to try to improve this
measurement dimension it will come from
many different areas when I started off
in venture capital we measured only IRR
then we got to a multiple of the capital
invested in the end it was both these
parameters that interested investors and
that settled down around that I think
we're going to go through trial and
error with impact measurement and it
behooves us all particularly as
prestigious a business school as
Stanford it behooves us all to help to
address these issues Heidi and Matt what
what do you think about the the issue of
measuring the impact of the enterprises
I think it's obviously it's it's really
important and I do think it's it's
critical to achieve scale and impact
investing will fail if we're not able to
attract trillions of dollars of inflows
into the market if we cannot pull
commercial capital into this space we
will not solve these problems so and I
think impact measurement is critical to
making that happen I think the trick is
trying to find a methodology that's
rigorous enough to be meaningful but
practical enough to be repeatable and so
whether Y Analytics has landed on it you
know gears has tried this Irish tried
this and I think there there are real
practicalities that are worth thinking
about whether you know small
under-resourced firms can hire
consultants to implement a complicated
methodology or if money is better spent
by focusing on the large funds that do
have those types of budgets the thinking
about how can we really make sure that a
method all
is rigorous but really executable by
smaller under-resourced firms is gonna
be really critical I think to to seeing
its scale yeah I would agree with what
said I would I would note that why
analytics has already made a significant
contribution to the field and there's a
lot to yeah and there are gonna be a
whole host of different approaches that
will all have to sort through and see
which is most applicable depending upon
the the situation and it's not gonna be
easy at the end of the day you know one
of the expressions is impact is in the
eye of the beholder what means something
to Sir Ronald as a significant impact in
somebody's life may not mean that to
somebody else in the audience so there
are a whole host of issues we've got to
take on this issue significant progress
is going is being made there's a lot to
be done I think we're still in the very
sort of early innings of the impact
measurement well it's just worth worth
emphasizing Matt's point that impact is
in the eye of the beholder
you know finance risk-adjusted financial
returns can be estimated across every
every investment in the world impact the
the the social impact depends on what
your goals are and you may be interested
in this in the sustainable development
goals you may be interested in working
neighborhoods in the UK or in health in
a US city and those are different goals
one thing that I think the impact
community has not focused on yet is the
unintended negative consequences of some
impact oriented businesses I wonder
whether whether you've addressed that
question I think when you're dealing
with lives unintended consequences are
crucially important and certainly in the
pay for success field it with social
impact bonds and development impact
bonds it's something that is central to
the design of these securities I think
when we are talking of impact ventures
such as those people in the
audience today might plan to set up
trying to address a social issue or an
environmental issue in health or in
education or in any other issue that
you're passionate about does not involve
having to prove that everything that is
going to result from your organization
is going to be positive impact and I
think when we talk about impact there is
a danger that we view it as the
Philosopher's Stone able to deliver more
than a normal profit for purpose
business and through its accounting some
how to account for long term as well as
short term impact and I think we have to
be more measured in our objectives I
think that for me what impact investment
means or impact entrepreneurship means
is the intention to address the social
issue in an effective way
measuring the financial return and the
impact created and I think over time as
we are finding with social media
companies today our perception of the
impact created may change we may
consider that at the beginning your
company is delivering great impact and
it's accounting will reflect that and
then over time it drifts away from that
in one way or another expected or
unexpected and the accounting will need
to reflect that at the time but we
cannot today in trying to prepare the
accounts of a social media company
expect to include in its sales line the
product impact of in the next 20 years
and so I think Paul it's important for
us to simplify and to ask ourselves what
is the purpose of a corporation is it if
it has
food products is it just to feed people
in high-income countries if it begins to
feed people in low-income countries will
we encourage that by giving them a boost
to their sales line because if you begin
to provide product to low-income
countries and you're possibly solving
issues of nutrition and so on so forth
and I think starting from something like
that or starting with the impact on
water utilization the impact on the
training of the unemployed starting with
these issues begin to put together
metrics that we will build up over time
I mean what's important is the way you
phrased what is the purpose of the
corporation is all of your answers
assume we've moved beyond Milton
Friedman saying the only purpose of the
corporation is to provide money for its
shareholders yeah when when I spoke at
the Y analytics meeting in Davos Baba
Zimmer who is the head of Chicago
University as as you may know was there
and I referred to the fact that it was
rather nice that he was in the audience
because Chicago had famously come up
with the Milton Friedman doctrine but
interestingly I said Chicago also came
up with the concept of risk measurement
and risk adjusted returns and as you
were saying before Paul we don't measure
risk very accurately but risk thinking
changed the face of investment
portfolios across the world it opened
the door to all of us um you know on
this panel because if he didn't have the
you know you didn't live through that
period and I did but a typical portfolio
when I kicks off in my mid-twenties for
a big pension fund was 70% bombs and 30%
equities all of your own country there
was no concept of diversification and
Chicago brought the concert
to risk-adjusted thinking so I think the
Friedman doctrine is behind us I think
the world is gonna have to move beyond
it in order to write to all of the ills
that confront us today but the
University of Chicago may yet be able to
get a Nobel Prize for optimizing
disparate I'll have impact in in the
five minutes before we then turn to
questions from from the audience the the
very rapid capitalization of the t PG
rise fund can be regarded as a success
but it could also be regarded as a worry
with respect to impact washing and let
me turn briefly to the question of the
impact of the investment itself but we
know what it means to make a difference
for the investing organization for the
business you're investing in for the for
the invest store what makes a difference
is you're doing something more than the
ordinary commercial investors would do
is there is there a potential worry and
let me begin with Matt and Heidi and
then probably finish with Sir Ronald is
there a worry that large funds like TPG
rise are really not doing anything
different in terms of impact than lots
of other emerging funds that have no
impact claims it depends and in full
disclosure Pierre was a anchor investor
in the TPG rise fund and I was familiar
with it I think it depends upon the
organization my sense and knowing the
leadership of the TPG rise fund is they
actually do value you do add value
through those investments not only
actually begins even in the process of
due diligence if you do do your due
diligence well you're creating a very
significant financial investment you
frequently are able to raise a whole
host of questions to that potential
investor that are meaningful to their
business then there are a whole host of
questions around what happens post
investments and again I guess I'm just a
little biased because I know the folks
at TPG that they like to engage with
there
vesties post investment certainly at the
mini our network when we invest in early
stage even those firms where we co
invested with other VCS who are just
looking at financial returns if we were
able to get on the board
we absolutely felt like we could add
value to the firm and enable them to to
become more successful and frequently to
the extent we were on the board and we
were focused on impact
there was also an important voice to
have on the board of directors because
not everybody on the board of directors
would necessarily have an impact
orientation so having an investor that
has an impact orientation and perhaps
it's a little self-serving for me to say
it but I like to think that that was
that was valuable to the firm in which
we invested so I think it's a great
question I think there probably a number
of situations where a firm that is doing
good in the world is able to attract
plenty of capital and so where the
impact investment may not be additive
but I think there are a whole host of
situations and periods of time in the
Verge's evolution were absolutely that
impact investment and the people who are
actually making those investments can
add a ton of value to that organization
yeah Heidi I think certainly TPG rise
has had a net positive impact on the
market you know certainly there are
those who I think criticize from the
outside that they are taking what the
Growth Fund would have done anyway and
reclassifying those into the rice fund
and so I think but you know they have
been extremely well capitalized right
and so I don't know enough about the
portfolio to pass judgment on that from
the outside you know I do worry a bit
that other other institutions will see
that race to a wem and want to be a part
of it and won't replicate some of the
things that TPC Rhys has done so
thoughtfully whether it's around Y
Analytics whether it's hiring folks like
Rick Needham or my ature angle or Tarun
Goodman who have been leaders in
pioneers within the impact space and
bringing them in and integrating them
into the investment selection process I
don't know if other firms will take as
as thoughtful of approach and I do worry
that you know
perhaps the market because it is still
new and growing doesn't have the
absorptive capacity to have TPG rise
replicate itself 10 times over today I
mean certainly we see mega funds within
the early-stage VC space really
distorting with what's happening within
seed stage investing series a investing
where fund size is dictating investment
strategy versus other way around so I
see things like that happening within
classic venture I worry that this race
to AEM you know led by this incredible
example of TPG rise and how quickly it's
grown may replicate itself within the
impact space and I think you know what's
important for us as practitioners and
for all of you as future practitioners
is to keep up keep up the heat keep up
the inquiry into how the decisions are
made how the strategies get formed and
how the investments are selected sir
Ronald why don't you take the last word
on this and then we'll open it up to
some questions so I I would say I agree
with everything that's been said by the
panel I would say that impact investment
is a response to the needs of impact
entrepreneurs who want to improve lives
in the planet in a similar way that
venture capital and Nasdaq were for tech
entrepreneurs and that it's very
difficult to separate a market into its
components we need change at the
investor level we need change at the
investment manager level and we need
change at the entrepreneurial level and
I'm glad to say that this change is
beginning to be visible at scale so
let's not seek perfection let's seek to
scale let's multiply the examples that
prove to the world that it is possible
to make money and to help others to do
good and to do well at the same time a
great benediction before we now we're
ready to take some questions from from
the
I sees somebody right in the middle of
the front Radhika
co-president of Stanford angels and
entrepreneurs I have a question around
the SDGs for Ronald Koeman
um do you see the SDGs as since they're
a normative framework that most world
leaders have adopted can they be brought
in to bring into the corporate charter
whether it's a company or an institution
or a venture capital firm that purpose
and intentionality for impact is there
even if it's not in accounting and also
the second question is is there a way
that the impact investing industry can
tackle the issues that have been there
in philanthropy around agency and I
didn't see not being as strong across
all the stakeholders and be more
egalitarian is there something that can
be done with us teaches and technology
in that space so I think the STDs are
very important and when we're thinking
in terms of impact accounting frameworks
like impact weighted financial accounts
I think it's very important that they
translate into a monetary contribution
to achieving the SDG Goals the SDGs have
become a sort of North Star now for a
lot of corporations and for a lot of
investors and we should build on we
should build on that thank you very much
my name is matthias and second year MBA
student so we took that in order to this
revolution to happen we need measurement
and more money my question is what is
the role of governments and policy and
what is the state I started off with
government as a partner but if you look
today at where government is government
is following rather than leading in the
impact space and so out of a hundred and
thirty five social impact bonds in 26
countries more than 90 percent have been
paid for by government
it's been long laborious and difficult
and so now we're beginning to say let's
have government's as partners let's not
expect them to do everything let's have
them pay for 15% of the outcomes let
philanthropists
come in and provide the other 85% over
the outcome so the outer is governments
are crucial if you don't get them as
partners you achieve very little but if
you rely on them as partners you'll you
know rely on them to do everything you
will achieve even less so at the moment
we're focusing on partnership with
governments working through the g7
working through the g20 different
countries Argentina I don't know if I
come from Argentina
Argentina is a country where impact
investment is is taking root we're
seeing legislation come in different
countries half a dozen countries have
created impact wholesalers like big
society capital the UK liberated 400
million pounds 600 million dollars for
big society capital and social
investment bank Japan is liberating four
and a half billion dollars for similar
purpose and so it's very important to
keep government's in but how you get
them to lead when in their mind it
involves doing new things which is still
not proven is a big question we have
covered an incredible amount of ground
in in one hour
thank you sir Ronald and Haile Patel and
Malik thank you
you
[Music]